when when we're watching the show and
that game pops up first yet
you know somebody's passion project
right right and you you say to yourself
please God don't let it be uh bleeding
edge but see bleeding edge wasn't a bad
game not at all the problems with
bleeding edge was I think it needed more
time to cook because when it came to the
personality of the game the music of the
game the Aesthetics of the game
everything looked perfect it was just
missing some gameplay elements that I
thought that could take it to the next
level and if it had more time to cook in
the cooker it would have been so
um but one of those games it's one of
those stories so everything has to hit
in this rare occasion
this one game comes out and it hits
because visually it's nostalgic
audio wise it had known bands right so